hello I am Jake Roper here for Wired and
I want to show you a day in my life here
at Comicon come in
so I wanted to meet with a few artists
because one of my favorite parts of
comic-con is artist alley and near it
there's just all these amazing booths hi
Russell hi Jake
hi Mark Wheatley hi good to see you he
does about these Star Wars posters how
did you get involved why are they
amazing I think they're amazing because
Star Wars is amazing I was trying to
come up with an idea for a poster if it
had come out in say 1957 what would the
poster have looked like I am doing
covers for the Doctor Who series that
are coming out I was also thinking of
movies like metropolis and Chaplin's
City Lights where progress and
Technology were really an important part
of the film but that was one of the
things that Lucas was trying to get
across is that technology without
humanity is is meaningless and and
basically evil and that's that's the
point of Vader he's technology with no
humanity you got really deep with these
posters that's problem-solving and
that's for me that's that's really the
fun of art so how do you go from this to
this well first of all I do a lot of
research on Matt Smith I figure out what
he looks like how he moves and then I
draw that up and then I ink it as a line
art drawing then I went back to the
original painted it up with watercolors
using that as a guide I started painting
in the computer and that's what I end up
with the fact that it appeals to so many
people seriously dude chokes me up under
the best circumstances it's really great
especially with digital work until it's
a tangible object it's not real every
single printed copy isn't original
there's a guy named Joseph Campbell and
he said basically that you should follow
your bliss and if you're able to do what
you love you'll always be fine Russell
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak with us and show us these amazing
posters that you've created it was fun
mark thank you so much
great talking taking the time
so when we get to the Doctor Who event
there was just this massive line that
went all the way around the block these
people look lined up for hours and hours
just waiting to get in they were dressed
up in their outfits and they were just
so pumped
the crowds loving it I'm about to go
onstage and kick off the stack of whoo
thing it's gonna be amazing
I'm so excited
oh you all look so incredible I'm going
to do a costume contest with five
amazing people I mean it's free cuz you
get to highlight these people who spent
so much time and so much effort making
these incredible outfit my goodness how
are you
are you i yes do you wanna
uh-huh
hello Cyberman so how long ago did you
start making this suit I started about
eight months ago weekends and evenings
when I had a little spare class you know
what is the suit actually made it what's
the main material in a material for neck
down is called EBA foam or anti-fatigue
mat and was this the first big cosplay
piece you've made first ever yeah really
nice
so I've done a lot of woodworking in the
past I've done a lot of graphic design
way to learn a lot of skills and do a
lot of research but there's a lot of
people online like on the replica prompt
or on YouTube videos there's a guy
called wonder squid who has some
fantastic patterns like Adam Savage says
you learn one skill and it builds upon
it to live another skill on another
skill and they're all kind of playing
together so I figure I'm gonna be really
good at auto body repair and there's a
lot of fun doing it and then may we see
the man behind the mask absolutely look
at that though the special guests we had
Jenna Coleman Michelle Gomez Steven
Moffat and Peter Capaldi the doctor
how has this changed your life I'm not
often fund and on stages in San Diego
talking to thousands of wonderful people
just being there with the audience were
freaking out was a sight to behold let
me tell you the Doctor Who thing was
amazing his dream come true and Peter
Capaldi even signed Chris's Cybermen
costume so it was interesting to see
both mark and Russell and how they work
differently mark was very focused on the
art and how he brought it to life and
then Russell was very focused on the
thinking behind it the process of how he
would just oppose these images to create
something more than just art more than
something that's just pretty something
that actually flows together but just
everything today was so cool I don't
know I was just very lucky to be a part
of it and I'm also glad that you got to
be a part of it too so thank you for
joining me and I will see you next year
and be sure to subscribe to a wired the
YouTube channel it is fantastic there'll
be more videos from comic-con and if you
really liked me talking to you for long
periods of time then guess what I have
my own channel called vsauce3 and you
can check that out by clicking here
maybe just one of the pepperonis